So, let's begin.
Aawdubillahi mina shaytan nirrajin bismillahi rahmani rahim Alhamdulillahi khalikal wujudimin al-Adam waja'ilin noori mina zulam wa mukhrijis sabri minal-Alam wa mulkit taubati ailan nadam fanashkuruhu aalal masa'ibi kamanashkuruhu aalan ni'am wan nusalli ala rasulahil akram lis sharafil asham wan nooril atam wal kitabil mahkam
Wa kamalin nabiyina wal khatam Sayyidi waladi Adam aladi basharabihi isabnumariyam Wada'alibi asatihi Ibrahimu alayhis salam Haina ka na yarfa'u kawa'idabaytillahil muharram Asallallahu alaihi wa alaihi wa salamu ala adba'i khairil ummam aladi barakallahu bihim kafatan nass al-araba minhum wal ajam
Wa sallallahu ala amir al-mu'minil an anza al-baqin waqa'id al-qur al-mahjalin ghalib ala kulli ghalib matlubi kulli taalib Alhamdulillahil ladi anzala ala abdihil kitab walam yaja Allahu aywaja alhamdulillah iladi lam yat takhizwaladan walam ya kun lahu sharikun filmulk walam ya kun lahu walium minadulli wa kabbir hu takbira
Alhamdulillah, Alladinahmaduhu wa nastainuhu wa nastakfiruhu wa nukminubihi wa natawakkalu alai Naudubillahi min shurui anfusina wa min sayyati amalina man yahdahillahu falamudillah wa man yudlilhu falahadiala wa nashaduan la ilaha illa Allah wahdahulah sharikalah wa nashadu Anna Muhammadana Abdullahi wa rasulu Arsalahullahu ta'ala bilhuda wadin al-haq liyuzhirahu aladdinikulli wa kafabillahi shahida
Rabbi Sharahli Sadri, Wa Yasirli Amri, Wahlu Lakhtatam, Lisani of Kahu Kawli, Allahum Mathabit Na'indil Mauti Bila ilaha illallah, wallahumma ja'alamin Aladina Amanu Muhammil Salihat, Watawasaw bil Haq, Watawasaw bil Sabr, Amin ya Rabbil Alameen.
Once again, Salaam Alaikum warahmatullahi wa barakatu.
So, as Muslims, learning about our Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam,
And learning about the respect and the deference that is due to him is extremely important.
Because the Prophet has rights over us.
And so I want to begin by exploring a verse from the Quran and a hadith that complements the verse.
So Allah says in the Quran, Qul-in kuntum tuhibun Allaha fattabi auni yahbibkum Allah.
Allah is commanding the Prophet to say, that tell these people, say, if you love Allah, then follow me, meaning the Prophet, and Allah will love you.
Similarly, in a hadith, our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam, he said, la yu'minu ahadukum hatta akuna ahabba ilaihi min walidhihi wa waladhihi wa nasi ajma'in None of you truly believe
until I am more beloved to him than his wealth, his parents, his children, and even his own soul.
Now the question is, how is my belief in Allah, my Iman, dependent on whether I love the Prophet or not?
What does it even mean to love the Prophet?
Because this is a very profound statement.
prophet said that a man's faith his Iman is not complete until we actually love him more than we love anything in the world anything that's precious to us and he named those things right parents children all people including the self because we all love ourselves Jesus said love your neighbor as yourself
And the assumption there in that statement is that we love ourselves.
So love them like we love ourselves.
And that's part of human nature that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he made us love ourselves.
It's a means for our survival.
But what's really interesting to me is that according to this verse and this narration, the key to a successful Iman is love.
Because that's what he said.
No one of you is a believer until you love me.
So he connected love with Iman.
Now, what is love?
Love is actually an amazing word in Arabic.
There are many words for love in the Arabic language, but the essential word is hub.
In Arabic, that's the essential word.
Our prophet is Habibullah.
He is the beloved of Allah.
All messengers have titles, right?
Kalimullah, that's Musa because he spoke with Allah.
Khalilullah is Ibrahim because he was the friend of Allah.
Isa is Ruhullah because he brought the dead to life.
So all of these prophets, they received a title, but our prophet is given the title Habibullah, the beloved of Allah.
And this title is obviously superior to all the other titles because the one you love transcends speech.
Because the nature of love is that it's inexpressible, right?
The English word love is an old English word that goes back to a Saxon word.
And it relates to being pleased with something.
Now, interesting enough, the word Iman
is also related to love.
How?
Because you believe in what you're pleased with, right?
You believe what you love.
The things that your heart accepts are the things that you believe.
So in Arabic, the word hub, which is the word our prophet used, no one is a true believer until I am beloved to him.
If you look at the root meaning of the word hub, it actually means seed.
Habba is a seed in Arabic.
Now, what do you have to do to make a seed grow?
You have to nurture it.
So love is a seed that's nurtured with the knowledge of the beloved.
The more you nurture the seed with water, the more it grows.
The more you learn about the beloved,
the more you will love the beloved.
So as we get to know the Prophet and as we get to know him intimately, the deeper we will fall in love.
And the deeper we fall in love with him, the more it will transform us.
Because love by its nature engenders within us a desire to become what the beloved loves, right?
And then another beautiful aspect of a seed, a Habba, is that it produces an endless harvest.
You begin by nurturing the seeds, which ends in a harvest, right?
You gather the yield of one season, but then what happens the next season?
It grows again.
You harvest it, it grows again.
Again, you harvest it, again it grows.
So love or Hub is the same where it just keeps on growing indefinitely, there's no end to it.
It keeps increasing in intensity with time.
One of the descriptions of love they say is it is friendship on fire.
That's how they describe love.
That it is something that begins to consume you, right?
It turns into .
And people have accomplished this at remarkable levels in our tradition.
You know, we have people
from our tradition who literally died in the love of the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam.
That's how much they loved him.
They literally died.
We have stories of people that bled tears of blood.
And tears of blood, which is an old blues motif for people who know anything about American music.
You know, there's that song, I'm crying tears of blood for you.
Tears of blood are actually real because when somebody gets into this very intense state,
Those little blood vessels in the eyes, they burst.
And so tears of blood is a real thing.
I think in medical terms, I think it's called hemolacria or something.
But there is something, I mean, poets use this all the time in their poetry, this concept of tears of blood.
That just by remembering the places the beloved used to go, caused people to weep these tears of blood.
So there are people in our tradition who have literally died from Ishq.
Now this word Ishq is another amazing word in the Arabic language.
It comes from the root word Ashaka, which is a type of vine that begins to grow around a tree
and strangles it, eventually killing the tree.
So the metaphor is that, you know, this tree, it falls in love with this vine and it offers up all of its nourishment to feed its beloved, right?
And starves to death in the process.
So it's such a beautiful metaphor.
And this is something, you know, only someone who has ever experienced this type of true love can really appreciate these things.
If you've never tasted love, I mean, this is going to seem ridiculous to you.
But if you ask the ashaq, right, if you ask the one in love, that starvation in the service of the beloved, to please the beloved is like the most beautiful experience of his life.
The Arabs say, , that
This type of crazy mad love is a deadly disease that can only be cured by a connection, by being connected with the beloved.
It can only be cured by a union with the beloved, right?
So the love of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam can really take hold of the heart as you get to know who he was and what he did for us.
Now, when you love somebody, you constantly remember them, right?
That's one of the qualities of love.
You constantly think about them.
That's what happens when you fall in love.
You call them up, you know, oh, I'm just thinking about you.
I can't stop thinking about you, right?
That's real, isn't it?
It's real.
I just can't stop thinking about you.
I mean, why is that pressing on the heart?
Because you're in love.
And that's what love is.
You know, I just can't stop thinking about you.
You write poems.
What is that?
It's a fusion that's coming out of your heart to write these poems.
Really?
And people write the worst poems when they're in love.
But it doesn't matter because they would never do it if they weren't in love.
Because they would know how ridiculous it is.
But it doesn't matter because
You know, there has to be some kind of taabir when you have this kind of love, you know, some kind of expression.
in Arabic is what you express, right?
The word , which is also used in Urdu, right?
The word means a discerning lesson, like a moral lesson that you gain from an experience.
And the word for a bridge in Arabic, it's because it helps you cross over.
So you get from one side of the mountain to another through that bridge.
From one side of the river to another.
So a discerning lesson is the same way.
You cross over from the state of ignorance to the state of knowledge.
And then that experience of that profound realization that you got out of that discernment, what does that do?
It brings out the tears, right?
That's why a tear in Arabic is called Abara.
Abara actually means a tear, because it crosses over from inside your eyes onto your cheeks.
So you can see how all these different meanings, they connect with the same root.
I mean, this is why I find Arabic such a beautiful language, SubhanAllah.
Also, you have that word, right?
Even in Urdu, which means trust, comes from the same root, Abara.
Because trust is like a bridge between two people that keeps them connected.
The path is open both ways.
You break that trust, that bridge collapses, right?
So this is Arabic linguistics where everything is, you know, all the different variations that stem out of a root are always connected in meaning.
Anyway, so what I was saying is that these emotions of love, right, they need a tabir, they need an expression, they have to come out.
They need to cross over from inside the heart and manifest into actions.
Because love has significance.
And when something has significance, it begins to affect the heart.
And this is why even the remnants of the beloved become valuable to the lover.
Even the remnants.
This is Jahili poetry, this is ancient Arabic, you know, this is poetry of Amr al Qais, where he says, let's stop my friends, let's stop and look here at where the beloved used to be.
And let's weep over the traces of the beloved, you know, just to look at these traces.
I think these were people that really knew what love was.
Seriously, they had a deep and profound understanding of help.
They really understood love.
And they were extremely intense in their love.
Not like this modern day ridiculous love that is portrayed by Hollywood and Bollywood in which this guy is chasing a girl around a tree and singing songs or this kind of superficial love that begins in a cafe and ends in a bedroom.
No.
That's not love.
That's just lust.
It has nothing to do with love.
But these ancient Arabs, they really knew what true love was.
That real experience of intense love.
So, that's one of the motifs of just Bukaalalatlal, you know, just weeping over the places where the beloved used to be.
Amaru ailad diyari diyaru laila.
Uqabbilu daljidaru wazaljidara.
You know, I passed by the house of Laila, and I kissed the walls of the house.
This is just so beautiful, right?
I kissed the walls of the house, but it's not the walls.
It's not the walls that have enraptured my heart, but the love of the one that used to live between these walls.
I mean, this is why we travel to Makkah and Medina, right?
This is why we go for Ziara, to Najaf, to Karbala.
It's not the places.
It's not these stones.
It's the beloved who used to live there.
It's because the feet of the beloved walked that ground.
And at the end of the day, this is what it's all about, right?
That's all this is.
I mean, these places, these walls, they're just hiding the eternal love of God.
That's what this world is, according to our Islamic theology.
When you begin to recognize this underlying emotion of love, you realize that that is essentially what you love about this world, not the dunya,
Right?
Allah praised himself by calling him Rabbul Alameen.
Alhamdulillahi Rabbul Alameen, not Rabbudduniya.
Right?
He said, praise and gratitude be to Allah who is the Rabb of Alameen.
The Alam is what the Arabs call Ismul Ala, right?
They call it a noun of instrument.
This Alam is an instrument of Ilm.
it's an instrument by which you gain knowledge you come to know of something and what you come to know using this instrument of this world is the Aleen which is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala this world this universe is God's vehicle for giving us knowledge and this is why things are so important to us right this is why ashia possessions are important
This is why property is one of the essential reasons why we were given the Sharia.
It is to protect property because possessions are important.
Why?
Because they give us meaning, right?
Your possessions are your instruments through which you create meanings in your life.
And the Prophet, this is why the Prophet used to name all of his things.
I mean, he didn't have many things, but the things that he did have, he always named them because they had meaning.
And that is what this world is to a believer.
It's all meaning.
The whole thing is ma'ana.
The poet says, ...
that this whole cosmos is just meaning set up in images.
this entire universe is just meaning set up in images and whoever understands that is from the people of discernment the people of Ibar Allah says in the Quran think deeply reflect look at this world with a discerning eye that's where you get Ibrah and then the Ibrah leads to Abrah you know that's when the tears come
Because tears, they always come from the perception of meaning.
You know, somebody gives you a really meaningful gift.
Why do you start crying?
Why does that happen?
Because your heart gets moved by that.
It's not the gift.
It's the emotion with which that gift was given.
That brings the tears out, right?
So meaning is a great gift that Allah has given us.
And this is why the Quran, it calls its verses Ayat.
which actually means signs literally, you know, and ayat in Arabic is a sign.
Now considering the fact that the Quran is a book, right, it's a kitab, you would think that Allah would have called this message, this text sentences within paragraphs, within chapters, right?
Because that's what a book contains.
But no, Allah calls them ayat, which are signs.
Why?
Because by definition, a sign or a symbol is something that points to something else.
A sign is always a means to an end.
It is never the end itself.
If I see a sign that says hospital 10 miles ahead, right, my goal and my final destination is the hospital, not the sign that reads hospital 10 miles ahead.
so the verses of the Quran are called ayat because they are markers they are signs pointing to something else what are they pointing to?
they're pointing to the signs within the universe signs within creations so you have ayat al-Qurani the signs of the Quran pointing to ayat al-Kaunaini the signs within cosmos within creation within universe within the soul itself
Now for a believer, what are the signs of the cosmos pointing to?
They're pointing him back to Ayatul Qurani, the signs of the Quran.
So a believer is constantly in this loop.
He's moving between these two signs.
The signs of the Quran direct him to the signs within the creation and then the signs of creation point him back to the signs of the Quran and together they both point to the creator of both.
which is Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala.
You see?
That's why it calls its verses Ayat.
Now, how do we interpret signs?
The human being, unlike any other creation has been given this gift of an intellect, which is essentially the tool to recognize signs.
That's what the intellect is, right?
You see dark clouds?
You recognize it as a sign that it's going to rain.
Right?
You see smoke, you recognize it as a sign that there is going to be there's some fire or some heat somewhere.
That's what the intellect is designed to do.
It's the same thing with language.
It is made-up of signs and symbols, alphabets.
Right?
Symbols put together.
If I read a sentence, this is a book.
I don't just stop at seeing those individual letters and symbols.
I put them together, right?
The the, the H, the I, the S, right?
Because on their own, they mean nothing.
The letters mean nothing.
The alphabets mean nothing.
If I wasn't illiterate or if I was unlettered, then all I would see is some symbols put together that mean nothing to me.
But because I'm literate, alhamdulillah,
I can interpret the letters.
I can put them together and I can read that what this is saying is this is a book and I can understand what it means.
So these symbols, they translate into meaning for me, right?
Same way this universe and everything within it are signs that signify Allah's oneness.
The ayat of the cosmos and the self, they mean something.
They read something.
What do they read?
Sanurihim ayatina fil aafaqi wafi anfusihim hatta yatabaiya nalahum annahul haq We will keep showing them our signs in the horizons and within their souls until it becomes absolutely clear to them that all of this is from al-haq.
All of this is a sign of Allah.
That's what the signs of the universe means.
All of this is from God.
And just as a literate person can read language, a literate intellectual, a believer, he can read this world.
Believers can read their own souls.
So a believer is someone whose consciousness is literate.
He can see what the signs of the world are pointing to.
They're pointing to Allah's existence, to Allah's oneness.
Allah's reality, Allah's awesome majesty, Allah's immeasurable beauty, His infinite mercy, also His wrath.
It points to Allah's kingship, Sultan, right?
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So from that perspective, we all have access to the existence of God.
I mean, you don't even need the Quran to read this cosmos.
and come to the conclusion that it has a creator.
If you are utilizing and fulfilling the power of your intellect.
If you can read the signs.
And once you reach that conclusion on your own that this cosmos has to have a creator, all the Quran does, it just clarifies things for you about the creator.
Who is he?
What does he want?
Why does he want it?
That sort of stuff.
Now, according to our Islamic theology, what is the purpose of human beings?
Why did Allah create human beings?
The ultimate purpose of creating human beings is to know God.
To recognize the oneness of Allah .
And to know God is to love God.
So Tawhid then becomes the ultimate purpose of creation according to the Quran.
That's what God wants.
He wants us to make him unique in his life.
Ulhu Allahu Ahad say that Allah is unique.
That's what Allah wants.
What about us?
What do we as human beings ultimately want?
Not Muslims, just as human beings, irrespective of race, creed, religion, you know, what do we
ultimately want.
We all ultimately, what we're searching for, what we're looking for is sada, felicity.
We want to be happy.
But in the Islamic tradition, happiness is not a state.
Happiness is not a state you can be in.
Like you can't be happy.
You can feel happy.
But you can't be happy at any point in your life.
Happiness is actually the sum total of your life.
It's the end result of your life, whether you lived a happy life or whether you lived a miserable life.
I mean, that's the sum total.
And that is calculated based on what you did in your life or how you lived your life, right?
According to the Greeks, it was all about virtuous living.
what they called Arate, you know, which was a life of excellence.
This word Arate in our tradition, it translates to the same thing as Ihsan.
You know, you have Islam, Iman and Ihsan.
So the whole purpose of life is happiness.
There's no other purpose.
Our purpose is Sa'adah.
And Sa'adah or this happiness, this felicity, unlike anything else in life is an end
Not a means.
Everything else is a means.
If you ask people what they want, you know, average people that haven't really thought deeply about things, if you just say, you know, what do you want out of life?
Well, you know, I want to have a family.
I want to be successful.
I want this degree.
I want to make lots of money.
Or, you know, I want to look sexy or have six pack abs or want to
be fashionable, dress a certain way, be looked a certain way, whatever.
I mean, they'll give you a lot of different reasons.
But then if you start probing those reasons, why do you want money?
Why do you want power?
Well, it enables me to be free.
You know, I can do things that I can't do without money.
Why do you want to be free?
Why do you want to do those things?
And if you keep probing that way, right, the end result is always
always happiness.
Because in the end we want to be happy.
We want to be in a state of contentment.
So Felicity happiness is the essence of what we as human beings are out for.
But most people don't realize that and they don't understand the difference between you know what's really good and what's apparently good.
You know, like people think that fame is good in itself.
So there are all these people who just want to be famous.
They want to be known.
Or they think that stature is a thing that's good to have.
Or, you know, they think money will make them happy.
So they'll sacrifice the real good in their life.
Like family, like health, like peace of mind, relationships, like character, like modesty, like courage.
like generosity these are the real goods but they'll sacrifice them for what they deem to be the ultimate good in life what is apparently good right now what Revelation does is that it turns this idea on its head that there is no Sa'adah in the dunya you can't get it because no matter what you have you can lose it
That if you're in good health right now, you can drop dead.
If you're rich, you can become poor.
If you're beautiful today, you'll wrinkle and shrivel up in time.
If you're strong, you'll become weak with age, right?
History is filled with examples.
Even the things you have and you do enjoy right now, the means, you only enjoy them for a short amount of time before you just want something new.
Something else, something more, right?
I have the iPhone 11, can't wait for the new iPhone 12.
Why?
'Cause I think that's what's gonna make me happy.
So we're completely enslaved to these means, the wealth, power, fame, body, stature, how many likes we get on Facebook.
And we don't even realize how enslaved we are.
Put your phone away for one hour, I challenge you.
Turn your phone off for one hour, kids, right?
My daughter starts having convulsions when her phone, the internet is not working.
I mean, that's addiction, that's slavery.
So these illusory means to the ultimate end goal of happiness.
In reality, these are chains, these are shackles that keep us trapped in the dunya.
So the Quran puts forth a proposition.
It invites us to freedom from everything.
You see?
It calls us towards freedom from everything.
How?
By becoming the willing slaves of Allah.
It creates this paradigm shift.
It switches our focus
from these millions of means that that we think are going to take us to the end of happiness it switches our focus on one central entity which is Allah the ultimate end goal of happiness.
It doesn't stop us from acquiring things but it changes the perspective and the meaning of those things that I can enjoy everything this Alam has to offer
Because it brings me closer to the knowledge of the Alim.
And so once we submit to him, once we channel all our distracted energies and focus it on this one central entity, we become free.
By submitting to the one Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala, we become free of all other submissions, all other slaveries, resulting in a life and an afterlife that is filled with Sa'adah.
with never-ending felicity this is why the Quran says we did not create Jinn or man except for willing servitude we did not create Jinn or man except for Saadah except for happiness which can only be achieved through a willing submission to the Creator
the word Abd is a very powerful and comprehensive word in Arabic the word Abd refers to everything that is ontologically dependent on God whether they believe in him or not a Abd is that which cannot exist on its own which is everything right so everything besides Allah is an Abd of Allah from that vantage point
because of its dependence on him but then the other meaning of Abd is those that embrace that dependence those that accept that dependence by directing themselves to Allah by worshiping and serving Allah so there are these two levels of servitude in the meaning of Abd one is ontological dependence which all creation share
And then a willing dependence by those selected for devotion, which only the people of Allah share.
Now as human beings, we can only willingly submit to the one we love.
Because Abd, the second meaning, the more profound meaning of Abd means willing submission.
And we can only willingly submit to the one we love.
That's how willing submission works.
It cannot be forced.
You cannot force anyone to love.
You cannot put a gun to someone's head and say be a Muslim.
It doesn't work that way.
You have to submit.
This is why you always fall in love.
It's a falling.
I have never heard anyone say I rose in love.
They always say I fell in love, right?
Submission, it absolutely requires love.
But in the process of falling, in that process of submission, you rise in the eyes of the beloved.
Isn't that true?
In the process of falling, in the process of that submission you elevate yourself in the eyes of the beloved.
How?
By becoming the best version of yourself to make the beloved happy.
Isn't that true?
You become obsessed with pleasing the beloved.
And in that process, you free yourself from pleasing everybody else.
Everyone else, you don't care.
All you care is the pleasure of the beloved.
You don't care about anything else.
...
walaytal lathi baini wabaina ka'amiron, wabaini wabaina lalamina kharabu, idha seha min kal woodda, fal kullu hayinin, wa kullal lathi fau katurabi turabu.
If I get the sweetness of your love, I don't care if my entire life becomes bitter.
Right?
If you are pleased with me, I don't care if everybody becomes angry with me.
Wa laita lathi baini wabaina ka ameron wabaini wabaina alamina kharabu as long as what's between you and I, as long as our love is flourishing, this world can become derelict, you know, I don't care.
If a sahamin kalwuddha, fal kullu hayinan
If I have your love, then everything is beautiful to me.
Otherwise, everything on the face of this earth is just dust to me.
SubhanAllah.
I mean, that's what love does, right?
That's the power of love.
I saw this advertisement for learning Italian a few years ago.
It was one of those
language learning DVDs and you know they showed this farm boy who's in love with this Italian celebrity and they tell him that he's gonna have one chance to meet him I don't know if you've ever seen this ad but they tell him that you're gonna have one shot at meeting this celebrity so he wants to learn Italian to be able to speak to her just for one moment this was just an ad right of learning language but whoever designed it he really understood love because
Because when you're in love with someone you will do anything.
You will go to any extremes for the beloved.
You'll learn a whole new language just to spend one moment with the beloved.
I really hope you experience true love at some point in your life because Allah made love in this world.
He gave us this gift of love.
This worldly love, right?
He made it to show us what divine love is supposed to be like.
He gave us love to make us understand how to love Allah.
It's a Hujjah, a proof against us.
You know these stories of Laila Majnun or Romeo Juliet.
These are proofs against us.
Because if this is the love of a created thing for another created thing, then what should be the love of a creation for his creator?
Right?
If that's what, you know, if that's what you'll do, if you'll go to these links for another person, then how far should you go for your Creator?
And this is where Rasulullah SAW comes into the picture for us.
You know, this is where his submission, his servitude for his creation comes into play.
He loved Allah so much, that Allah made His love a necessary condition for the acceptance of our love.
Say if you love Allah then follow me and Allah will love you.
Why?
Because loving our Prophet will transform us into someone that Allah will love.
Which by the way,
is a very inverted concept if you think about it right Allah should be the beloved because he's the creator and our prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam he's just a creation creation is supposed to love the creator not the other way around but what we learn from the Quran is that Allah is in love with this man sallallahu alaihi wa sallam what does that tell you about this man
Quran is filled with Allah's expression of his love for his prophet.
These names, these beautiful titles that he uses to address his messenger.
He swears by things.
I mean that is love.
Why does Allah love this man so much?
because he used his free will to submit to Allah and in the process he transformed himself into the best of creation Allah fell in love with the qualities exhibited by this man this is what Islam is this is what Islam is all about this is what Sharia is all about we have a religion that is
based in love that is full of love.
Islam is a love-based religion and anyone who tells you differently has not understood this religion.
Wallahi, I swear to you, the one thing I have consistently found in my years and years of study is love.
We as creation are an expression of Allah's love.
Everything the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam did for us was out of pure love.
If you read his Seerah, that is the one consistent emotion you'll find behind every action.
And he didn't need to do this.
He didn't need to do any of it.
You know, just as Allah, as the creator did not need to fall in love with Rasulallah who was his creation, Rasulallah did not need to love us.
he did not need to suffer and face hardships in his life to guide us he did not you know he didn't need to lead us out of darkness into light but he did it anyway why because of that love he had for us that selfless love and so it is only fair to return love with love because you cannot love Allah without getting to know him
and without falling in love with his beloved which is Rasulullah this is why he said none of you are true believers until you love me until you get to know me because I am the one that Allah fell in love with because loving me will naturally transform you into someone that Allah loves love is a fire
right and fire softens and it bends steel fire allows the iron smith to mold a shapeless useless piece of steel into something beautiful which then graces the mantle of your house right burning in the fire of our messengers love is going to mold us into something beautiful that Allah would want in his presence
this is why he is the greatest sign the greatest ayah of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala a living role model the one that Allah wants us to emulate and as I said love will naturally engender submission and through our willing submission to the free by submitting to the one who is free to the high we ourselves will become free
And we will elevate ourselves to realize our greatest potential for which we were created, which is true happiness, sada, felicity, the ultimate purpose of life.
.........................